I'm Jeff garland this presentation is
about the c++ 20 standard library mostly
not about ranges and there's a bunch of
other topics that aren't going to be
talked about as well I'm going to tell
you what I didn't talk about and so
you'll at least have some pointers the
I've been here for every one of these
conferences and recently I hadn't talked
much but more recently I've been able to
get back into working on standards and
back in 2007 I helped with the original
chrono presentation and and
documentation and and so I'm getting
back into it now and I thought it would
be useful to try and record everything
that's going into C++ 20 even when it's
not quite there so we'll talk a little
bit about that here's the list of goals
there's a bunch of stuff on i/o new
facilities there fmt format is the big
one will probably spend more time on
that library than anyone else general
support utilities there's a whole list
of smaller and medium-sized things in
here flat map and span some larger size
containers view type things and then a
bunch of things with containers and
algorithms there's a major update to
Crono which I'll tell you about and then
some smaller stuff at the end if we
don't get to this stuff we don't get to
this stuff but we will try to get there
so as I said and as obvious from the
title the big thing we're not talking
about is ranges ranges is a huge change
to the library it's a complete overhaul
of the algorithms I have a talk on that
tomorrow so if you're interested in that
subject I'll be covering that tomorrow
there's a bunch of other smaller or
things that I chose to just take off the
list 3-way compare support any and
vocable what
is also called unique function and all
the proposals today you eight string and
string view context Berg
that's what this conference is
apparently largely about this year
there's a ton of new context per and
various algorithms in container I'm not
going to talk about it I'm also not
going to talk about no except there's
been a lot of parts of the library that
have had no except added to them as part
of the C++ 20 and I'm not going to talk
about that I'm also I'm going to talk
about variant algorithm vectorization or
atomic graph
Mateusz talked about those yesterday in
his and we just don't have enough time
okay
so just the level set things all do and
won't do in this talk I'm going to show
you something that will not be in C++ 20
so I'm afraid that right now and I'm
going to show you the state of
everything as we go through this talk
there's a lot of things that are still
in process and I'm gonna go through this
a little bit more in a minute
I will take questions until we kind of
get behind and I think I have a pretty
good idea how long this talk takes so
I'll kind of know when that is I'm gonna
defer anything I don't know unless
somebody in the audience knows which is
the typical thing here and no doubt I'm
going to get something wrong this is
just a very complicated set of
facilities and it would be impossible to
get everything perfect so I'm gonna show
you a lot of code I'm gonna shorten up
namespaces I'm gonna leave outbound
includes I'm going to do a lot of that
kind of stuff as usual but I'm generally
not going to show you something I
haven't actually tried to compile I'm
gonna tell you women I didn't try to
compile this stuff it's a little bit
different for me I like to try things
before I give a presentation on them
because I learn things about what they
actually do that you can't seem to tell
from the specification strangely so the
environment I mostly have been using for
this is Linux GCC 3 different versions
of it benign trunk as of mid
March - now then 2019 normally I'm
compiling with F concepts and usually
with C++ 20 not that that means anything
right now very much and in this case for
these libraries there's a lot of
different libraries there's a lot of
github repositories that I had to
download and and get the reference
implementation I also mentioned to you
that I spent a decent amount of time
communicating with authors of these
libraries because what you find out when
you start digging into the status of all
these things is it well there's a few
things that aren't quite there yet and
so as best I could I tried to get
information from the actual authors
where I could so I think this is the
best information that's available right
now so what's the implementation status
right now C++ 20 is feature complete
there will not be design changes except
for in response to defect reports at
this point the Cologne meeting which is
in July is the end that's when the CD is
going to ship and it is going to go so
anything that is not finished in that
cologne meeting in July will not be in
in C++ 20
I really like this cpp reference page I
don't know if you've seen this one this
is a very handy page to look at it shows
you all the language and library
features across all of the compilers I
know all of the compilers have their own
individual pages here but those are also
linked at the bottom so this is like the
one page for all and I don't know how
they keep the status up to date I don't
know if it's fully up to date all the
time but I encourage you to use that
link I'll also mention the current
working paper if you don't know about WG
21 link that's working group 21 that's
the C++ standards committee and 48:10 is
the current working draft I refer to
that all the time it's an interesting
question the committee likes to say that
the standard is not a tutorial but I say
that it's very helpful to actually go
and read the synopses and other things
that the library
components okay so with that let's dive
in so the first major component that
we're going to get is STD format this is
the FMT library and it's really a Python
type style string formatting capability
that's being lifted into C++
it supports named in positional
parameters custom type formats and in
general it's a much faster engine than
io streams with less overhead and I'm
also going to show you later today that
the input output for chrono which is a
new part of C++ 20 is integrated with
fmt and that took some some doing on the
part of a variety of people there's a
new header for this and if Marshall were
here he would say we're getting a lot of
new headers in C++ 20 and that is
definitely the case okay so let's look
at hello world this is a basic code I've
got fmt here because of course that's
where the library is currently these
will all be STD instead of fmt you can
see this is very simple syntax you have
curly braces in the format string and
then you have a very attic argument list
that is matched up against those braced
elements in the format string so very
simple the parameters can be of any type
all of the standard types that you know
and love will work out of the box so I
can do something a little different here
if I want to have a little bit of
control over the order of the parameters
I can use index parameters so in this
case we have two indexes 0 and 1 because
of course all indexes start at 0 and
those are the positions in the argument
list so in this case what's happening is
42 and hello are being swapped one thing
I cannot do is I cannot mix
a non-indexed parameter specification
with an indexed so that will be a
compile time here yes I think the use
case is probably internationalization
because of course you don't have to pass
this as a you know const char star in
the point of this it can be something
that's generated in a variable somewhere
else right yes I should repeat the
question the question was what was the
use case for swapping for example okay
so another capability that this has it
has the ability to actually name
parameters so in this case we have two
parameters one name num and one name
wrld and then there's this little helper
that's used this fmt argh
and this argh in the list allows you to
actually name the parameters and so
again now what you're able to do is
match in the format string a named
parameter that's in the list so this is
going to give you some pretty
sophisticated capabilities okay
we got a question in the back can the
name parameter occur multiple times in
the format string I do not know the
answer to that I doubt it though I'm not
sure we can check later can we use raw
literals that is actually a string view
and I don't know if a raw literal I
think that will convert to a string view
so yes okay Chandler says yes so then
for sure yes Thank You Chandler right
right so the question is how can it be a
compile-time error if it's somewhere
else and the answer is it can't be and
I'm going to I'm going to get into that
in a little bit okay all right so what
if
we want to do indexed and named together
that's possible I'm not sure what the
use case for this is but I assume this
is a capability that Python supports for
some reason it's a capability of the
library supports and is in the standard
anyway it gives you a lot of flexibility
for defining your format string in I
will tell you that this is just the
hair's breadth so far and I'm not even
going to get into the business of all
the numeric formatting capabilities this
library has it is extensive so let's
talk about one issue that surely is
coming up in your mind is what happens
if I need to put braces in the actual
string well so you get to escape braces
by using another brace so I guess we get
to have fun with braces so in this case
you can see when the format string is
resolved the untouched one of the brace
sets is removed but the other braces are
escaped and remain so basically this
prints right here there were two now
there are one this can get a little bit
crazy because I believe this is
essentially recursive so in this
particular case what you're going to see
is we're able to put 42 within this
double brace but it actually becomes a
single brace in the actual output and
have fun with braces so I'm going to
give you one numeric formatting example
and I'm gonna give you this one in part
because it illustrates some other
capabilities of the library here so one
of the things you'll notice here now is
that we have a width and a precision and
so this is a floating-point number where
we basically want to say you know 10.3 f
right so we want the format type to be
like this but you'll notice that in this
case we're actually influencing the
internals of the format string itself by
passing parameters in
okay so you'll note that there are three
index parameters here zero one and two
and this is actually saying the zeroth
parameter here's the format string the
colon separates it and the two and one
come from here and there so you get ten
point three F okay so you have some very
sophisticated capabilities to generate
the format string even within the syntax
itself okay
custom types so let's say I have a
custom type what am I gonna do with that
well in this particular case this type
the system doesn't know anything about
it it's not going to work it's not going
to compile so how do you extend for a
custom type this can get interesting
depending on how complicated you're
trying to get but basically in this case
what you are doing is you're making a
specialization at the formatter and that
is going to have to return a formatter
string view format some machinery down
here in this case all I'm basically
doing is got a switch statement that
changes the enumerated types into
strings and I'm returning that back okay
if you want to have a custom language
for your format for your special types
you can do that too we're not going to
go through that here but Crono is
actually going to do that and take
advantage of that capability so there's
a large amount of extensibility here for
your own types as well it's going to be
different and I'm sure it's going to
take time for everybody to adjust on how
to do this
Vittorio does it find stream operator
overloads let me repeat that because I
didn't talk it to the mic so does this
find existing stream equate overloads
for example oh stream no but I'll show
you some things where so really what
you're formatting into you'll know
here is strings in general you know so
you know but there are I believe there
is also a print function and that can go
to a stream okay wait okay the library
supports formatting using like the
stream output operator so if you have a
type that has to the stream out operator
define then he's gonna use that seems so
right okay you need to include a special
header so by default but I'm not sure
that's in the stand I'm not sure about
that yeah so we would have to check on
that to be sure I don't believe it is
but yeah I'm not a hundred percent sure
on that it's a good question alright so
be assured you can do your custom types
so let's just talk for one second about
performance here you know performance is
always something that's important to C++
programmers this is a little bit old so
it's an older version but you could see
that at least with fmt there was a lot
of care taken at least in the integer
realm to try and make the formatting
extremely fast so you know lower is
better here you can see at the bottom
STD to string and booze format and I
don't even know what compilers there's
the link at the bottom you can go follow
it and go read the whole blog post but
you know this is Victor's blog post
itself and again this is from a few
years ago but this is the kind of thing
that we like to see where we're going to
get highly optimal performance of foucan
alright so now let's talk about
diagnostics and safety so what can go
wrong
currently all of the diagnostics here
are runtime diagnostics so they're
exceptions and in theory if you write a
you know char star star format string
you could imagine that that could be
runtime checkable I think Hannah
presented in the key
almost all the machinery that would be
necessary to do that
checking however is not the case and it
is not specified and standard that that
is what is going to happen so what can
cause an exception so one thing is if
you have the wrong count of parameters
so I'll show you examples of these if
you have names that don't match if you
have types that don't match in all of
those cases that you you can get an
exception so we looked at this very
carefully about whether we would put
this into production and we have held
off because we're not sure we can keep
ourselves from doing things like putting
this in a catch block or putting in an
untraveled untested piece of code that
isn't going to be executed for a long
period of time that's the practical
practical realities so don't use it in
catch blocks or other places that are
not exception friendly would be some
basic advice or you're going to have to
wrap things in a try-catch so let's look
at them here's an example I have one
parameters I have 2 format strings it
doesn't like that yes and again the
library supports compiled time format
streams checking it does not it does
unit I know for a fact okay well you and
I can we can get out the compiler later
and I'll show you exactly what happens I
compiled all of these exams you you you
need to like passage string literal
inside a macro so like fmt stream sure
us doom literal yeah and then passed
that to format so let's let's be clear
so the the comment is that the current
library supports it with macros not as
that as in the standard he's an you this
I've had this conversation with Victor
and and he very much wants compile
everybody wants compile time checking of
strings in this case but of course if I
pass this as a as a you know an argument
that's variable it's not gonna be
possible anyway but in the case where
I've written it like this clearly I
would like to have that compile time
checking I think there's some general
hope here in that the compilers
already know how to do printf and some
of these other things now so they're
doing some special things yes Vittorio
so in 20 we have you know generalize
don't type template arguments so as far
as understand there's nothing preventing
us from having an overload it takes the
string literal as a normal argument for
runtime parameters and what it takes
into my angle brackets for compile time
yep I'm not saying it's not possible I'm
just saying it's not specifies not in
the standard and it's not in the
standard and it the implementers do not
have to do that so the interface is what
it is until somebody implements it out I
think that we will get there
I mean I'm convinced that there's enough
people that want to use this kind of
capability and that want the compile
time checking if it can be done and the
technology seems like it's there so okay
a couple more real quick
I've got the name numb up here I got the
argument name number down here that's
incorrect I get an exception when little
pet peeve about the library it doesn't
tell you which argument mismatched if
you had a long string that would be a
problem Chandler yeah so Chandler's
comment as compilers can just add it
that'll be great I sure hope they do
yeah yeah yep okay so Chandler saying
we'll just go and add it we're gonna
mark that down and you'll get to
implement it you're gonna regret saying
that all right all right last one
this is a type based one and I actually
I was looking at at Python for
inspiration here and I actually pulled
out from this little tutorial an example
and there was an automatic type
conversion here you've got a floating
point type and a decimal type here 42 42
well guess what
C++ won't do that
conversion for you in this case whereas
Python actually will there are other
kinds of format strings in this library
that will allow you to do some kinds of
conversions okay that's a lot that's the
probably the most you're gonna see on
any library but this one I think is
critical for every C++ programmer I'm
sure every C++ programmer will use this
I would be shocked if they don't so what
is the status of this p645 is the link
there's the FMT library go experiment
with it be aware there are things in
that library that are not in the
standard but it's in lwg
it has been reviewed once and maybe
twice actually so we've been working
with victor on trying to get the wording
in line so it can be in Cologne there's
other things that I'm going to show you
in a few minutes
that are dependent on it so I really
think this will get in Towe know they're
there I just didn't show you show them
to you yeah yeah it's a big library with
a big surface area so the question was
are the print ones there and yes they
are so it's a quick question on the type
safety side obviously from the example
in to double doesn't work do the other
integer promotion bits and pieces work
yeah so the question is will other
integer promotions work I think so but I
will be a hundred percent sure I didn't
try it so I'll leave it at that we got
two more here and then we'll probably
have to move on the performance yes the
report that was a runtime performance
graph your mileage may vary but Oh
compile time performance yeah you know
listen I I compiled small stuff and so I
don't I don't know that there's any
metrics on that at all
I don't expect it to be a-okay
so the cop coming is he's got a few
hours of compilation time so he cares a
lot I don't think it's gonna be a huge
issue yeah
print is not in that paper oh it is not
it is not okay no will it take
containers no no okay let's move on sink
buffo sink stream so in multi-threaded
app applications it's very easy to get
your streams garbled up if you're
sharing a stream between threads you can
definitely get yourself into some
trouble there's a long history I think
is mostly in the concurrency working
group they were working on this issue
many many people have run across this
issue there's probably five six seven
papers associated with what should we do
with the library to solve this so what
you're gonna see today is the solution
that came out and it allows you to wrap
up a stream and have an independent
buffer and then synchronize the transfer
of that buffer into the underlying
stream appropriately there's a new
header called sink stream this is what
the code will look like and I will say
this one I did not compile so this is
something I just worked with Peter on
but anyway it looks like a stream like
any other stream oh sink stream but
you're wrapping up in this case see out
which is a contrived example because I
think in most cases see out is actually
probably pretty safe anyway in the the
sea synchronization winds up
synchronizing but in any case other file
streams in general are not protected
so this buffered output object here has
its own internal buffer and even
when you do an end L which is going to
flush the buffer here it's not actually
going to flush to the sea out at that
point okay it's only gonna flush
actually when it's destroyed and there's
actually an underlying call called omit
which is the thing that flushes it to
the underlying stream buffer so here's a
different little example there's some
other little utilities you can change
this behavior so here I've got a file
stream and output file stream and I'm
gonna wrap another buffer around it that
one when compiled probably because of
scoping but in this case there's another
function here called emit on flush and
that changes that ndele behavior so emit
is called when you do flush the buffer
those are question ah yes you're hard to
see in the lights can you - so in the
first example if you want to sink out
should I have just one object of our
sink stream for whole program or should
I have or can I have like multiple
objects yeah so the question is can I
just have one object or do I have
multiple you're gonna have to do that
everywhere right because they're going
to have to synchronize against each
other so and so I don't I don't know
that the solution is gonna work for
everything but I think you can imagine
for example you know just as an example
we have a logging thread safe logging
library and we have to synchronize
multi-threaded things this kind of
facility actually would probably do most
of what we need to do another question I
do not know the answer that question is
is the omit function no except probably
it is but I don't know for sure we'd
have to go look at it pull up the
standard you'll find out
yeah so but yep oh that's good question
so the point was just let me make the
point the point over in the audience
here was well it's gonna run in the
destructor it better be no except yeah
okay all right well interesting okay so
it says that it catches the exception
and ignores the exception if it's thrown
so it's effectively no except so here's
a more realistic kind of example where
you might apply this let's say you've
got multiple threads and you know you're
gonna do some kind of function here
against the file and you're gonna do a
bunch of complex code so the so sink
stream is only gonna flush when you exit
this function so just a little bit more
realistic motivated motivational example
this is what the header kind of looks
like standard kind of stream header if
you've ever looked at these things you
get basics versions of things and then
you'll have the the usings for the
various char types so standard streaming
stuff this is in the working draft
already so this one is going to ship and
there's the references to implementation
and so forth now Peter told me that in
general you really kind of need your
library vendor to really do this well
because of the internals of the
streaming and so forth so you know
you're probably really gonna have to
wait until this comes out in the
compilers and standard libraries all
right the next library is a little
another little streaming utility called
a stream joiner again it's a wrapper
around a stream but it takes a delimiter
and that delimiter is then interspersed
between the values that are inserted
into the stream okay and it has the
interesting behavior that it has ability
to not insert after the last one in the
stream which is very convenient if
you've ever had to write the code for
say you know JSON streaming or so
and it acts like a normal stream just
like anything else so here's a little
bit more interesting example I wrote
just to try it out I've got a function
here that takes a container type and it
takes some de limiters and it takes an O
stream and so this allows me to just
print out any kind of container that I
want and what I do first is I insert the
start delimiter into the stream and then
I construct a no stream joiner with the
delimiter that's passed in or defaulted
as the case might be and then I just
copy the entire thing into the o stream
joiner which pushes it into the
underlying stream and then I put the end
delimiter on and return the stream nope
nope
so the question is do I need to flush
here and I don't believe that would be
the case it may flush under the hood and
I don't know that so that's a good
question
[Music]
well the delimiter yeah so what's the
lifetime to the limiter the delimiter is
obviously going to be gone at the end of
the function it's going to already be
written yeah yeah yes right so the point
is if you had two different so that yeah
so this is assuming exclusive access to
the stream so what's that the last curly
bracket is in this code right here yes
at that point yes
oh J is every already written everything
yes yes
okay so this is what the code actually
looks like so vector strings vector
events etc it just prints out some nice
stuff in the case where you give it some
kind of empty collection you know
basically you get braces empty braces
and you know because I'm returning the
stream that I can stream stuff right
into it so okay so references this was
actually in the fundamentals to TS
michael Sporus has the example on github
which I was using there's some cpp
reference information on this as well
because it was in the experimental I
don't know if anybody actually
implemented it I didn't really go look
and see if anybody had to implement it
in their compiler and so forth okay
we're running just a little behind but
we're doing okay so flat map and span so
flat map is really four things it's flat
set flat multi set flat map and flat
multi map and despite what you might
think these are not actually containers
they're container adapters and they are
an alternative to the they are an
alternative to the standard set map and
multi-man and actually this actually
goes back a long long time it goes back
more than a decade there was an
interesting discussion I guess by Matt
Austin who I believe was the library
working group chair at the time I this
is the second time I brought up Matt
Austrian this is conference and he
discussed the fact that no one should
actually use set and his point was that
node based containers and red-black
trees weren't the only way to get good
fine performance and in fact there are
alternatives and that's exactly what
these container adapters actually
provide so this is really about a
different set of performance trade-offs
and we'll see some graphs on
not that you get a very different thing
so let me just put this very annoying
operating system you must upgrade away
thank you so one of the things this does
is it separates the storage for the keys
and the values even though the
interfaces look very much like what
you're used to and if you have some kind
of a mostly read associative container
you'll see that these are really good
they're not very good for something that
you're gonna have to insert into a lot
so let's look at the what the
performance looks like these come right
out of the paper is a clean whose here
at the conference this week you can talk
to him about this if you want he
generated these graphs
I took one subset of the graphs out
basically what you have here is you have
boost flatmap which is not exactly the
implementation of this STD from GCC STD
map from GCC and the split map T which
is Zack's a little wrapper version of
things and you can see in this case of
iteration this is a huge win you have a
flat line versus a very high slope as
the containers get big by the way this
is on a log scale so be aware so this is
where these container adapters really
shine the fine performance is
interesting it's relatively saying oh
the I'm sorry the other thing I should
have said is I didn't annotate this
unfortunately on the graph but the left
hand side is an int int mapping and the
right hand side is a string string
mapping they're not really that much
different in these graphs but just so
you know what what we're talking about
here so this is the same thing again
with find so of course this is the the
key thing that you're going to do with
maps and sets and so forth is do a find
and as you can see you know the
performance is somewhat similar and you
know you can see at the end there on the
right hand side the standard map is
falling behind by a relatively
substantial margin I think from a
theoretical point of view
from a practical point of view I
wouldn't trust that you're gonna get
better performance on find but I think
you can trust that the performance is
going to be similar in nature and
perhaps even better in certain
circumstances and I'm gonna show you why
in a minute and then of course there's
insert and we have the exact reverse
here which is to say that standard set
rocks or standard map rocks and flat map
is a disaster it's very slow and that's
because it has to reorder the internal
collections I had talked about that in a
second so the performance comparison
these are going to use contiguous memory
as their underlying storage so in
general you're going to get a lot better
cache performance on modern processors
we saw the iteration was faster you're
typically going to have a lot less
memory allocations and used in certain
ways you'll have none and in addition to
that you're going to get reduced memory
consumption because you don't have the
overhead of red-black trees node-based
container which takes pointer space for
every element that you put in faster
lookup mmm-maybe definitely slower
insert and erase so what does the
interface look like very straightforward
you could put you know STD map there and
it would be the same okay and here's a
little taste of ranges for you
there's iterating over a range in
Reverse and printing it out okay so
interface comparison to standard
containers first of all the iterators in
these are random access instead of
bi-directional and that's because the
underlying storage is contiguous for
keys and values and the keys and values
are separated actually into two
different underlying collections we will
see that in just one minute the
iterators which you might expect to be
stable in a regular map
in the face of insert and erase are not
going to be stable here so that's
something that is a definite difference
in the interface you should be aware of
in addition to that the types are going
to require to be copyable or moveable
and again that comes from the underlying
storage as compared to the storage in a
standard map and the flat maps and flat
sups are going to give you some
additional capabilities here to extract
the underlying container to replace the
underlying container and to do some
interesting things that you wouldn't
think about and Zac tells me that in the
very first review he got of this paper
some game industry people told him well
you're gonna make the containers of the
keys and the value separate right
because that's how we always implement
that right because it's super fast and
that's that's the best way to do it and
indeed that's where we are so one other
note if you're thinking about using
incomplete types because you used boost
flat map which definitely supports
incomplete types there's no fundamental
reason why these adaptors can't do that
but the underlying container types are
going to have to allow incomplete types
so if you're going to use like a boost
stable vector as your underlying
container type then we think it will
work there's the the standard doesn't
say anything about this and and of
course this is an old long history item
as well
vector probably should support it
incomplete types but it doesn't it never
will so the standard version of this
won't support incomplete types but you
can probably get a version that will if
you want so here's what the you know
flat map looks like it's got a key type
of value type T just like you'd expect
from a regular map or set a compare less
so forth so you can change that out and
then there's the two new ones the key
container type and the map container
type and you can see those default two
vector of key and vector of T
so I could not compile this example I
don't have a reference implementation
that does this that's a little bit of a
problem but and boost flatmap for
example does not actually do this
currently and i don't know what the
status of it doing it is but in any case
what we've done here is we've got a
vector a string a vector event
interestingly enough when you construct
this it's going to sort those may not be
the behavior you're thinking of when
you're providing it the collections that
you actually want to use so this is
again why this is an adapter and it's a
little bit different from that
perspective so let's say that you
already knew that those containers were
sorted and matched up with each other
the way you expected well you've got
another constructor here which has this
sort of unique T that you can pass and
at that point it just moves the
containers in so there's no allocations
it's constant time and you're good to go
so this is why I'm saying if you can pre
build it up yourself
you know something about your domain and
you can build up the map yourself you
can get really quick performance okay so
where are we at with this there's
actually two different papers our six is
the latest one is in the post cutter
release that's oh for 29 that one has
been reviewed by lwg
122 actually has the set pieces of it
that was done by le w G at the last
meeting that one has not been looked at
by lwg at all
Arthur O'Dwyer who's here at the
conference not in this room I don't
believe he is implemented flat set on
his own he's got his own github I did
not try that out boost flatmap mmm is
playing at the edges but not really
supporting this at the moment and
there's that reference to what Matt
Austin had to say a decade ago okay any
questions yes
I'm a question do you think that name of
flatmap will confuse programmers who
also program on JavaScript Java or use
some reactive programming where a flat
map its name of operation not name of
container right so that ship is sailed
already I know that functional
programmers don't like the fact that we
use map in general since that's a
function of course and so flat map
making it worse at this point is our
it's it's water under the bridge I think
all right let's talk about span so we
had a little conversation in the
presentation yesterday span is an
interesting thing it's sort of a view
but you'll notice it's not called span
view and that's in part because it has
the ability to modify the underlying
sequence and so I think out of abundance
of caution it was going to be the case
that constants and a lot of other things
could get a little weird here so we
didn't really want it to be a view even
though that's really what it is it's
it's really a way to look at a sequence
and it's super cheap to copy because of
course it's just a pointer in a size
really and really all of the functions
on it are constant time so there's
nothing about span this oh yeah how does
it relate to the new category of
contiguous iterators yeah it it has
contiguous iterators so the begin end
functions on this will will give you
those yeah so yes
this is another assumption that you know
you've got contiguous storage as your
underlying things so it's going to work
with collection types that are of
contiguous contiguous memory or
contiguous storage already said that
this is also context for red
so you can use this at Kant's expert
time let's take a look what do I have to
do to construct one of these things I
got a vector event if I want a span
event I can just construct it directly I
have a little bit of a difference here I
have an array of size five I can wrap
you know span events around that I can
wrap it around a see array as well
that's nice so I can get nice type
safety when I call a function I can also
have strings and other types so I think
where this is really gonna shine where
you're really gonna see this get
utilized in a case like this where maybe
I want to just have a range come in as
my parameter and so I'm taking in this
print reverse here a span of int and I'm
taking it by value and what do I have to
do here down in my main I've got a
vector event I just passed the vector
event right into the function yes right
so the question is does seat add work
with span I don't see any reason it
wouldn't I don't know if those are
specified I didn't try I'm wondering how
it will work with arrays strings string
may contain a pointer to date the vertex
is located so they will be contiguous
original in memory I think though yeah
this is an STD array which is gonna be
contiguous but strings it will be array
of two strings right but text may be
located anywhere oh I see you're saying
yeah that's a good point yeah that's
good point yeah so the comment is the
strings are still contiguous but yeah
they're actually like a sub part of the
view in this case
so just as another note I'll just
mention yet another little piece of
Range code here once again I've got you
know reverse view here for whatever
reason I'm really in love with that at
the bottom here I'm doing a couple of
other functions here you'll note I've
constructed a span here and then I get
the first two elements out of the span
and send it to print reverse so I got
two in one that comes out and then in
this case I go get the last so I can
subset the span to smaller sections this
is a big class there's a lot of things
on it we obviously don't have time to go
through all of them but it supports
began and interfaces it supports
operator square brace and that's you
know where you can get into mutating so
you can index through you've got data
size empty and a whole other array of
things that you can do this there's also
this variation with static and dynamic
extent so you can specify that the size
of the span is only going to be five and
then it's going to have to match up with
other things that are size five okay so
this is already in the working paper
there was a tremendous amount of debate
about span across mini meetings about
its nature should it be regular what is
the size return etc and you know you can
talk to us offline if you really want to
know all the gory details but I think
it'll be fine alright one little bonus
with span oh sorry
we got a question down here I'm gonna
try to get the constants of this thing
so as far as I see it's always constant
it's a view it's a reference it's
actually not conscious at all but if you
look at the Constructors it actually
takes everything by non Const what I'm
trying to say is if I want to prevent
mutation can I say a span of constant
right I don't believe we can
that would be insane because they can
never have a view only span maybe you're
right maybe they look the recent changes
actually make it so that that will work
but in general the constructor for span
takes the collections not by Const so in
general that would apply to me that
wouldn't you know imply to me that the
underlying collection is going to be
modifiable so yeah maybe if you
construct a Const one it's going to give
you a problem it'd be an interesting
thing to try it's worth worth trying
okay yes sorry I can align pointers yeah
yes so the question is can it have
iterators instead of pointers I don't
think so I think it has an iterator or
it has a pointer in a size and actually
there's an overload for taking a pointer
on the constructor instead of a
collection all right I think we need to
move on so quickly there's a little bit
of bonus territory for span so span has
already gotten used and this isn't in
the i/o section but it's actually about
i/o who knows what SDR stream is oh wow
there are people under 25 in this room
that know what SDR stream is I'm
impressed I thought you had to be as
gray as I was to know what that was
so SDR stream is the please deprecated
set of standard i/o that's been
deprecated for a long long time but
there's been this problem because
there's a group of users that use the
one feature of STR stream that is not in
string stream and that is specifically
that you can construct a stream with a
buffer and so there's a new capability
called span buff and span streams that
go around it which allow you to use a
span essentially a span of char as your
input for a stream so if you're doing
things like you know oh I've got you
know a C array of chars and
want to use it nicely and safely you can
do that
so this one is library working group for
Cologne so it's one of those that's on
the bubble we don't know if it's gonna
get in again this is Peter Sauber Summer
lad he is here at this conference if
he's the guy with the hat so if you want
to talk to him about this one
you can almost almost at the destination
alright so I think we're gonna have to
pick up the pace so we'll probably be
skipping a few things here and go in a
little quicker so there are a whole
series of small container and algorithm
updates let's cover them very quickly
first an easiest one is contains four
maps yeah it's easier to read em dot
contains and that not equal to end stuff
so it's very simple this is added to the
associative containers for the
associative containers like set multi
set you actually have two overloads you
have the regular key type version and
something that can actually be
comparable the key type will also work
flat map and it's also have these
already for the unordered collections
there's only the signal signal single
signature sorry for contains because of
the hashing so there's your reference
this is in the working draft you're
gonna get that heterogeneous lookup I'm
not gonna go deep in this but basically
this is allowing you to have a
compatible hash function for different
types like string and string view const
char star is a canonical example so if i
want to be able to do these finds and
compares normally today what happens is
you're going to end up with a string
view being constructed into a string and
that slows down the performance so I'm
not gonna give you the example of how
you write this but this gives you the
capability to make those conversions
without actually having to construct an
actual string so this is in library
working group if we're Cologne there's
the paper number I did not have a
reference implementation for this one
uniform container eraser so who's ever
had a problem trying to erase something
from a container anyone ever made a
mistake oh my okay most of the room went
up so you know there's a problem there's
an idiom there's a way to do it
fascinating read in the paper
how many trapdoors there are there's a
huge number of trapdoors and I think you
know the Microsoft guys basically said
this is one of the most common requests
we get is some way to actually erase
containers so this is somewhat novel
actually what we're gonna have here is
actually collection based algorithms
which is something the standard library
does not have currently these aren't
really arranged algorithms they're
really collection based algorithms and
so anyway this was makes perfect sense
right erase erase if I've shown you the
list variant of it here but it applies
to all of the sequence types basic
stringing decklist
vector erase if can also apply to the
map and the multi map case oh by the way
erase if is one of the cases where or
one of the places where there's a lot of
the holes when you're using remove if
and the associative containers already
have an erase key type so that one is
not included so this is in the working
draft already and this is lifted from
library fundamentals to I did not have a
reference implementation which is kind
of a yes yeah so there's there's a
template signature for all of these
containers yes so so there's an erase
and erase if for all of those container
types yeah so pretty much whatever
container you have you should be able to
call that erase ah if you have your own
container it right you you can obviously
write your own yeah you're gonna have to
yeah okay so one other quick thing
related to removing this is a very small
change listed for word list we're
throwing
information and remove remove if and
unique where as a little inconsistency
with map and set that didn't do that so
now you can actually get the count of
the number of elements that were removed
when you call these functions and in
some cases it may be very important to
actually know how many elements were
actually removed this is in the working
draft I didn't have a reference
implementation comparing containers so
it turns out that this comes from
Marshall Clow and he was doing some work
on unit tests and really got frustrated
with trying to compare various kinds of
containers so like he had an array STD
array of five things in an STD array of
six things and you can't call equal on
those two because there are different
types it's kind of nonsensical when you
think about it because as it turns out
we actually have a comparison algorithm
that actually works quite well in the
face of this so STD lexicographical
compare is really what this is underpins
this and basically you're getting a
series of equal and greater or less and
not equal on containers to enhance your
ability to just compare containers so it
impacts the list of containers at the
bottom there and so it's using lexical
lexical compare under the hood you
should take a look at that algorithm if
you're not familiar with it it's very
interesting there's the link it's
library working group in Cologne I don't
know if live C++ is shipped it yet but
they've at least implemented it okay
couple more quick ones shift left and
shift right so these take these are
standard algorithms so these are range
algorithms but there will be range
versions of the there are standard
algorithms it just got added so they
just move the number of elements left or
right in the sequence and they return an
iterator to shift point I'll show you
that in a second so here it is
I have a vector event I'd say shift left
with the began end and I say shift - and
it's interesting because nothing is
harmed here four and five are still
there but then one and two have been
destroyed by three four and five so
you've been shifted left and the
iterator is pointing at the four here so
coincidentally if I call a race to the
end I can conveniently erase the rest if
I want to but in general the size of the
collection is left untouched so if you
actually just iterate over that
collection you'll get three four five
four five okay so be aware of that shift
right is basically the same thing so
there's the signatures this is merged in
the working draft there's a github for
the ship proposal that I use to test
this out there will be ranges versions
that is in in work it's through le WG it
is - lwg I believe we have looked at
that paper one time already but there's
a series of other other additional range
pieces in there all right I'm going to
skip over find last because I'll talk
about that tomorrow
so general support utilities and I'm
going to probably we're probably going
to get there let me just pull the room
who does bit manipulation in this room
on an extensive level Wow I guess we're
C++ programmers who does object-oriented
programming
I'm surprised well okay okay well we'll
see what we can do all right
so smart pointers these are quick simple
things there's Atomics and default
initialization there's a lot of
discussion about how should we spell
atomic shared pointer or atomic weak
pointer you know there's some things in
working R&T s's that
spelled it differently and so forth in
20 you're going to be able to say atomic
up shared pointer of T if you want an
atomic shared pointer so that's very
nice
this is merged in the working draft I
don't know that there's a reference
implementation for this anywhere
I didn't look carefully in boost but
there's the paper you can go look at it
another change to the shared pointer is
allowing for default initialization this
case comes up especially when you have
array types and you're going to
initialize them right after you make
them and so in that case you do not want
the default initialization that you have
of make shared or make unique so here's
what it looks like
you call this make share default in it
so that buffer of 1024 doubles that you
just made will not be initialized in any
way shape or form okay it's just going
to give you the memory for it and now
it's your responsibility to go
initialize that memory and use it
appropriately
so this one is merged boost smart
pointer supported it since 156 all right
functional programmers I forgot to ask
we got functional programmers in the
room okay all right so so this this
paper adds monadic operations so we know
we're in functional land right away for
optional there's three template
functions added optional and then or
else and transform and these enable a
nice interesting functional style I'll
show you an example I did not compile
this one so this one you know is just an
example this comes from the the working
paper but basically here you've got a
string an optional string that's 10 and
then you take the optional string and
say and then change it to an integer and
if it actually changes to an integer
successfully then transform it by
multiplying it by 2 so you can chain the
operations as long as you want as soon
as you get a null op you will not go any
farther down the chain and you'll return
null optional
okay so a very interesting you know way
to be able to chain operations together
we're starting to look like JavaScript
so there I said it
so this is a library working group for
Cologne there is an implementation out
there I didn't really play with it too
much
polymorphic value though this is for
your object-oriented programs this is an
interesting type and I highly encourage
you to read this paper this paper is
co-authored in part by Sean parent and
some other very very good people it's
kind of like an any for polymorphic type
I don't really like that
characterization though because really
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to create a polymorphic object that has
value type or regular semantics that's
really what we're trying to do and so
you're basically gonna have typically a
base class and derive types that you
plug in to this thing and I'll show you
a little bit of an example we're gonna
go through it real quick though one
thing to note is that there's no
standard hash for this so if you're
gonna use polymorphic objects with hash
containers you're going to need to write
hash but of course that makes sense
because how would the standard know how
to hash your types in this particular
case so here's kind of the motivating
example and they do a really good job of
going through this in the paper itself I
have a composite object and I have a
couple of components that are pointers
to a base type and I want to just
construct them manage them
I want this composite object type to be
a regular type what do I need to write
what do I need to use do I use unique
pointer to a shared pointer what are all
the things that I need to use it turns
out to be shockingly hard to do and so
this is the gap that polymorphic value
provides it allows you to write
something like this polymorphic type and
your type as members and then all the
regular nests and all the goodness of
regular types comes along for free and
so that's really what what the use case
is here like I say look at the paper
there is a github here this one somehow
I miss the status but I know it's
library we're
in group four cologne stat tres no
questions on stack trace are allowed
during the session you'll have to talk
to me afterward we're down to 22 minutes
and we got more to do and stacktrace is
obviously one of these questions comes
up a lot because there is a language
footprint here core had a lot of
conversations about this I'll tell you
that they're still interesting
conversations on the reflector about
certain elements of this and exactly how
they should be written but basically
this is based on boost stacktrace
there's a new header called stack trace
and of course if you're a a C++
programmer as long as I am you've
already written one of these and you
want one in the standard because you
don't want to have to maintain the lousy
one that you have for the last decade
and you're hoping that the compiler
vendors are gonna do good things for us
Chandler thank you and make sense of
this but obviously what you're going to
get out of the stack trace is going to
depend on you know many elements in the
environment that are beyond control of
the standard like what mode you're
compiling it so simple use case
construct a stack trace and it's going
to give you the flow of execution to
that point really the simple way to
think about the stack trace is it's
really a container
it has stack trace entries I think that
might have been renamed actually but
anyway a description a source file and a
source line or basically what it is and
I think the reason I'm thinking this is
renamed is because there's a thing
called source location which is set to
replace it that also comes out of
contracts so this is still a little bit
in flux another method I'll point out so
that I showed you the OU stream but
there's also a two string so you know if
you want to log it you want to put it in
other places you should be able to do
that hopefully all right again on the
bubble lwg in Cologne I don't even know
if we've looked at this one time
I think I'm gonna stop and go past
unreachable now yeah
well I was gonna mention one funny
little thing so if I show you this
signature is there anybody that doesn't
recognize with what this is anybody
that's locked into an earlier version of
C++
I'm sure there's got to be a ton of you
guys can't use this so this is an
attribute right which is a C++ 17
feature and it's a language feature
right but one of the things that's
happening is that there are more and
more attributes being created and
utilized and one of the new ones in C++
20 is no discard and there's a paper
that puts no discard on a lot of
different functions in the library
particularly things like empty and new
we're really you always are gonna use
the return function from new right I
mean you always have to yes question
yeah ass tributes have been in language
since 11 is it 11 okay my apologies
about like I think but I guess my point
was hard came in 17 yeah but like no
return was in the lemon yeah I think I
thought no discard was 20 but maybe it's
just the adding of it to these standard
library functions it's in 20 sorry yeah
yep
alright so the comment is that you don't
necessarily want to always just
deallocate memory for some particular
reason that doesn't mean you shouldn't
assign it to a variable which would be
what would stop the compiler warning
that's gonna happen alright let's talk
about chrono we have 18 minutes so we
might not get to all the bit things
we'll see talk briefly about chrono this
is a huge upgrade for Carano in 20 this
extends the existing capabilities of
chrono well beyond time points and
durations and such into calendar ik
functions and really one of the new
bridges that current no crosses here is
there's now a whole series of types that
are what are called field types or
structure types like your month day it's
just exactly what you think it is it's a
structure of a year month and a day and
these types have a special special kind
of function mostly they don't do a lot
of calculation mostly they're there for
i/o and getting things in in and out of
particular type there are some
calculation functions that go on there
but there's the calculation types or the
serial types I think is way Howard puts
this so like sis days time point seconds
these are actually really integers
usually under the hood unless you make
them floating-point which you should
never do but that's another story
but anyway so these types are very fast
they're very small in memory you can
store lots of them you can do lots of
computations additions subtractions and
so forth ok this is fully context we're
ready which is really cool you can
construct times in a you know in a
consistent way at compile time ok so
some simple examples here's a year month
day if you go to Howard's website he's
got hundreds of examples you know in
this case you have to do a little bit of
work
to get the year-month-day to construct
this way but then you can construct
assist stays from your month day you can
do stuff like add weeks to it you've
seen this in boost day time if you've
ever used that same kind of capability
and oh look wait whoa you oh streams you
you were a bit able to stream it out
nice and that's really the biggest
upgrade couple notes
Cronos air handling as compared to boost
a time which uses exceptions is very
different
chrono will allow you to construct
values and interrogate values with an
okay flag to find out whether or not
you've done something that you shouldn't
do that's out of range that's a very
reasonable design decision and it also
puts a little bit of burden back on
users to make sure that they're doing
things so if you don't care about weird
values coming out of your dates fine
don't check okay but if you do care
about that you might have to check the
ok flag on some of these types ok part
of the advantage of doing it this way is
again it makes context we're really
possible
okay so chrono i/o gonna go through this
really quick we're not gonna do too many
examples here's a year month day that's
constructed and now I want to format it
look I've got STD format here now and
I've got interesting what I got s printf
type characters here I've got percent MD
percent Y so that's the foolish American
way of putting dates and so I just put
that in and this is actually using those
extension facilities to expand the
grammar that grammar is extensive okay
there's a very very large grammar it's
kind of like what boost daytime has but
the Howards library also has had this
for a long time so it's very expressive
you can create almost any kind of date
and time stir
that you want to with those with that
grammar not everything is possible I
know that for a fact
there's also optionally locale aware
time specializations so I'm showing you
something that we're not going to talk
about more which is zoned time which is
a time zone time and in this case we've
gotten a locale and we've put it in and
that was an extension that date time got
into format so this is an optional
capability with format to use the locale
for that and that's really important for
dates and times if you if you've ever
done anything where you need to load
Eliza times okay there's a ton of other
features in Chrono it's really a talk by
itself leap seconds times on database
support localized times GPS clocks go
look at it it's fabulous it's the
library we've needed for you know 10
years at least
okay so references it's in the working
paper except for this format part so you
know give love to your lwg members to
get all this stuff in but look at cpp
ref it has a pretty good actually break
down on the format strings that Chronos
sports okay
bit manipulation let's see i got 12
minutes and so I think I'm gonna just go
like super fast there's a new bit header
in C++ 20 and it has a number of
different low-level functions will be
useful for some group of people there's
power functions I'm not gonna go through
them you can go look at the paper and
read it
there's rotate functions counting
functions these are actually not in the
power functions are in the working paper
these functions are not in the working
paper yet I don't think there's going to
be any issue getting them in so there's
a couple reference papers on the bit
manipulation and status I'm going to
skip over bit cast and talk just briefly
and Ian and I think this is another one
of those things where for a long time if
you needed to know what the endian nough
some oisin was you know you didn't get
any help from the standard now you've
got a simple enumeration that helps you
do that it's in type traits currently it
might be moving to bits I'm not entirely
sure on that so stay tuned where it
actually lands but you can use it at
compile time which is interesting so you
can figure out and maybe do Const expert
code based on the Indian Essene and you
can also use it at runtime so you know
standard if-else statements do something
different depending on the and enos of
the machine so there's a bunch of stuff
it's already in the working draft so
this one will definitely be there other
bit manipulation facilities you should
know and love by now STD bit set dynamic
bit set well look at that I got 10
minutes on the clock and 10 minutes on
the slide
it won't take 10 minutes so we'll have a
couple more minutes for questions so
miscellaneous topics math constants
question how many people need pie and
other math constants Kuwait quite a lot
interesting so there's a new header
called math there's a new namespace
called STD math and it provides a whole
series of floating-point value types to
the nearest representable value for that
particular type I'm showing you long
double there's float there's double
incantations of these things and so I
don't think this is even the complete
list there's a long list of them so this
will help you out when you're doing that
this has been already pre reviewed by
the library working group for Cologne
and Marshalls not here but I thought he
was gonna try and have a list review so
we could have it tentatively ready in
Cologne so we would not have to review
it obviously boost math has these
one thing you're not gonna be able to do
with this is you're not gonna be able to
take your special big number type and
just use these you'll have to take
whatever the supported double type
values are here because all you'll be
able to get out of the standard it
doesn't support customization for your
own number types a couple more math
functions real quick midpoint that seems
like the simplest function ever honestly
it turns out to be really hard there's
two different problems there's integer
overflow problem that's the primary one
and it turns out that Java had a bug in
their pointer logic under the hood for a
decade apparently associated with not
calculating this right and apparently
Mozilla JavaScript had a problem with
this function as well so apparently this
is a lot harder to get right than it
seems
it was also very interesting in Kona we
had a couple of to not be named very
experienced library development authors
attempt to on the fly actually write
this to the specification that's in the
paper by the way this was brought by the
National Labs and yeah it's surprisingly
hard to do it took well over an hour to
get an implementation that actually
worked in all of the cases it's
surprising so definitely don't write
your own in the same paper there's
linear interpolation which is about the
oldest thing in the world for graphing
and other things why is that difficult
well I'm not gonna explain it I'll show
you what the paper said this is the set
of capabilities that we want out of the
linear interpolation so for all of us
non mathematicians it might take us a
little while to actually come up with a
function that actually is able to do
this so the interface is simple give it
three floats and it'll linear
interpolate in between okay so there's
the references it's in the working draft
you're going to get it and this is it
last one string and string view new
member functions surprise you didn't
think that there would be new member
functions and string ever again
did you but there there are starts with
and ends with something that's very
basic and very useful that's in the
working draft and you will see it so a
couple of observations and maybe I
should have gone slower in bits but
anyway there were two slides full of
things I did not cover in this talk I
did not cover anything really with
respect to ranges concepts any of that
stuff in this talk the library changes
in C++ 20 are huge there's a lot of them
some of these things are really small
tiny tweaks on the edges bug fixes
really good fix ups clean ups some of
them are key building blocks going
forward I guess my overall observation
here is that we're still in catch-up
mode our standard library still has a
lot of things that are missing for
day-to-day programming that other
languages and other libraries have so
it's great to see the progress I think
in a lot of ways in a lot of ways it's
not fast enough but it's been mentioned
before the committee has only so much
bandwidth to actually do things I think
it's also the case that programmers only
have so much bandwidth so I don't know
if a few of you have been intimidated by
this talk and how much stuff there
actually is to go learn about I can tell
you that it took me an extensive period
of time to actually go through all these
papers to actually try all these
libraries out to talk to the authors
where I could it's not a trivial amount
of stuff to learn and this is the only
half of it so it I think is going to
change fundamentally you know the way we
do a lot of programming so I really like
this quote from Henry Petroski on kind
of a similar vein anybody know who
Petrovsky is
he's a civil engineer and he's written
extensively about bridge failures and
why they would happen and engineering
and so forth
and I thought this is particularly true
because when I was reflecting on the
number of decisions that had to be made
to get the standard library to where it
is today even the language of course to
where it is today there had to be
thousands and maybe millions I don't
know what the order of magnitude is tens
of thousands of conversations tens of
thousands of decisions it's really a lot
of stuff it really is so okay thank you
questions more questions give him the
microphone yeah is Indian merely for
detection there's no helper functions
for managing byte order or anything like
that no there's not none of the features
that you have in in boost Andean that
allow you to do those swaps and stuff
now so it it is literally the
enumeration that you saw on the scrub
slide yep mm-hmm Vittoria pasta I
checked spam okay there is an
implementation lip C++ standard and if
you put const as part of the element
type then it's an immutable view or
something so you're free to choose
between span event or span of constant
okay and that determines whether or not
you can mutate the underlying container
okay
well it'd be interesting to check okay
good good knowledge and so is that
already in shipping version yeah it's in
clan live C++ I don't know the exact
version but it wasn't got both with
trunk okay beautiful yeah spans been in
process for a while and I didn't mention
I think also in the standardization
process there's a multi-dimensional span
type for doing multi-dimensional arrays
and somebody that's doing linear algebra
is probably interested in that kind of
thing
other questions yeah there's no other
questions and you could go back to
unreachable sure let's go back to
unreachable we can do that thank you
oh there okay so what is it
it's a way to annotate branches that
shouldn't be reached in code and there's
some thinking in the paper that
implementations might provide modes
where maybe you're going to trap like a
debug mode where you might trap an
unreachable and provide a runtime
diagnostic now one of the things is this
is gonna allow compilers to do in
certain cases is optimize things and it
turns out that all the major compilers
I've just shown GCC here but all the
major compilers actually implement this
already as an intrinsic and so this is
again lifting standard practice into
into the standard for use by developers
so this is the motivating example from
the paper I have a function f takes an
integer I have two cases and I have a
default that I should never reach maybe
we shouldn't get into why you shouldn't
write your code this way but in this
particular case yeah you're able to call
STD unreachable invalid value of x might
be nice if you said what the value was
it was passed in but you're basically an
undefined behavior here that that string
is for Diagnostics so if you're in some
kind of a diagnostic mode you might
actually get that out of your terminate
function back here that is looked at it
at compile time but in certain modes it
may trigger in run time but in this case
it might allow the the compilers say I
can never get any other values of than
zero or one and try and optimize away so
here's another example which until I
read this paper I hadn't thought of this
clever idea to kill yourself that's an
interesting way to do it there seem to
be more direct
to do it but in this case yeah
this line of code will never never be
reached and so there's some couple of
simple signatures there's another
attribute no return and this one still
needs to be reviewed by lwg as well okay
all right oh---but cast well now we're
out of time I wanted to get out a bit
cast we can go there though so it's
essentially a replacement for
reinterpret caster Union when you're
doing low-level mem copy type
capabilities and so you have some memory
you copy it to another place and you
want to cast it into a particular type
it offers a little bit more safety and
that the sizes and things of the two
types that you're trying to cast have to
be the same this is already in the
working draft so you can you can go take
a look at it the motivation for this is
a little bit obscure and sketchy in the
documentation if you ask me but I guess
I can see uses forward in particular
where maybe you're taking something off
a wire and you're gonna cast it into a
type yeah yeah so the question is what
does it use inside and is it reinterpret
caster compiler magic and I assume since
it's got to enforce if you if you look
at the working paper you'll see it has
to enforce some conditions that you know
well reinterpret cast basically doesn't
enforce anything right it just does what
you tell it to do and bit cast will
enforce at least some conditions on you
so it has to do something a little bit
more yeah yes I have come to bat because
actually you can use it if you receive
by network by exam message in binary
format you divide it into like words
then you need to convert it from little
engine to big
Indian and then to correct converted to
the float or double right so that's
where you need it right so you're you're
basically operating directly on the
memory they're trying to get it into the
the memory of the machine and in that
cases the sizes aren't gonna change or
they can't really change they better not
change because otherwise this won't work
all right I think we're done time for
the picnic
[Applause]